generative AI has arrived with the
potential to revolutionalize the
consumer package goods and Retail
industries from enhanced product
development and supply chain efficiency
to personalize shopping experiences and
datadriven decision-making AI is
redefining the way companies operate and
compete and serve their customers
according to IBM's latest CEO study
industry leaders are increasingly
focused on AI Technologies to drive
Revenue growth in fact 42% of retail
CEOs and 59% to consumer product CEOs
are banking on AI Technologies like
generative AI deep learning and machine
learning to drive results over the next
3 years so how can cpg and Retail
businesses not only use AI but also
create value with it to truly stand out
from the
competition IBM's answer is Watson X our
Enterprise ready Ai and data platform
which helps business to capitalize on
the opportunities of generative Ai and
foundational models in three ways Watson
X . a is a Next Generation Enterprise
studio for AI Builders to train validate
tune and deploy both traditional machine
learning and new generative AI
capabilities powered by foundational
models through an open and intuitive
user interface what's the next. data is
our data repository based on a Lakehouse
architecture and an open data format
designed to manage Enterprise data for
foundation models with trust and
confidence whatson x.g governance is a
powerful set of tools to specify and
manage enterprise-wide governance
processes and control risk the wonx
platform has been developed in line with
four core and differentiating
beliefs open IBM's AI is based on the
best open Technologies available trusted
IBM as AI is responsible and
governed targeted IBM's AI is designed
for the Enterprise and targeted for
business domains empowering IBM's AI is
for Value creators not just users at IBM
we're not starting from Ground Zero our
company has a rich history of leveraging
AI in the consumer package goods and
Retail sectors to drive innovation in
product design supply chain optimization
and Trend forecasting building on this
history we understand that generative AI
holds a tremendous potential for
economic impact Research indicates that
applying generative AI across a series
of use cases can boost productivity for
Consumer package Goods organizations and
Retail businesses
driving incremental revenue of 400 to
600 billion annually for the industry
globally investing inative AI has the
potential to yield significant business
benefits but where can these
technologies have the greatest impact
according to IBM's recent CEO study the
top priority for these industries are
customer care cyber security research
Innovation supply chain Logistics and
fulfillment let's delve into some IBM
examples we we a a company in marketing
content creation streamlining the
process with AI generated text and
images enabling quick and easy promotion
creation we enhance customer service for
another company by leveraging AI to sort
and process emails identifying sentiment
validating information and rooting
requests efficiently generative AI can
predict the next word in a paragraph
This same sentiment can be applied to
data which AIDS in demand forecasting
we've helped a company use generative AI
to solve sales forecasts demand planning
Inventory management and waste forecast
by understanding the relationship
between performance and causality and
dependencies from many different aspects
we are seeing exceptional results when
applying generative AI approaches to
forecasting with over 250% performance
increases in forecast accuracy when
compared to other widely used machine
learning models we also see the
opportunity to apply generative AI
capabilities such such as summarization
conversational knowledge and content
creation to augment supply chain
planners accelerate issue identification
and resolution thus avoiding costs and
availability issues additionally we are
enabling client teams from Finance
supply chain operations sales marketing
and other areas to talk to their
Enterprise and external data and rapidly
understand performance what events are
driving sales what products are
delivering margin where are their risks
to availability which customer cohorts
are engaged and so on allowing rapid
intuitive insights to be gathered and
acted upon IBM is committed to helping
the retail and cpg industries to unleash
the transformative potential of
foundational models and generative AI
with IBM you're not just an AI user
you're an AI value Creator let's embrace
the age of AI value creation
together